second talking about public school one
moment so now you've asked me questions
I'm I'm going to answer it Tiffany
Justice uh she is the co-founder of moms
for Liberty I Know Tiffany I've seen her
at many events I think I've done their
podcast at least once or twice over the
years she is a absolutely lovely woman
who I think was mostly uh apolitical
throughout her life and then as they
were pushing all of this gender nonsense
and trans stuff and all of this stuff on
her kids and then her friends kids and
everything else uh she started a group
called moms for Liberty they're one of
the groups that started looking into
some of the books that kids were
learning uh that kids were supposed to
read they started looking into the
curriculum that they were being taught
etc etc she is by no honest assessment
and extremist or a right-wing Maniac or
anything else but of course that's what
the media calls her anyway she went on
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC to talk to Joy Reed uh and joy
tried to explain to her why children
learning about pedophilia should be in
public schools the question I'm asking
is what is the expertise that you have
and other moms for Liberty Advocates
have to decide that a book an
award-winning book like all boys aren't
blue isn't appropriate for students to
read what what a tragic story of a young
man who's annally raped by his adult
family member so you have incest rape
pedophilia Joy you said you'd let me
answer so I'm going to answer for you um
in what context is a strap on dildo
acceptable for public school just let I
mean that's my question to you tell me
what the context around the strap on
dildo or the rape of a minor Child by a
teacher second we're talking about
public school one moment right so now
you've asked me questions I'm I'm going
to answer it well who is the main
character what's the name of the main
character in all boys AR Blue you're
asking me right now you just gave me
very specific information about this
book so you're presenting yourself as
somebody expert the who's the main
character in the book The main character
is the author what's his name George I
believe is his first name because you're
giving me very specific information that
is ask remember the name of an author
just remember specific here's my
question talking you didn't answer my
question I'm going to I'm going to
answer your I would love to hear that
absolutely well I I'm interviewing you
and you're not interviewing me so let's
just make sure it's a conversation okay
great okay Joy is just so absolutely
unbearable that she tries to pin this
down on you don't know the name of the
main character she knows that it's
George she knows that it's an autobi you
know that it's biographical etc etc it's
just it's such nonsense and she knows
what the story is about but that's just
like a little trick that if you're a
really um dishonest host you can use on
somebody like if I'm interviewing
somebody and they kind of don't know
what they're doing there's always a way
you can really just get them on some BS
and that's exactly what Joy Reed did I
think even for the dumb brainlets that
are watching MSNBC they probably could
see through that first I want to just
say that someone has to decide what's in
curriculum so when Joy is like well this
is an award-winning book and why should
somewhat
no kid is taught the sum totality of all
information every year of their life
right every year you there are Educators
and and parents and board members that
get together to decide what is
appropriate for these children just if
you're watching this just think back to
when you were in third fourth grade
right think about your teacher I think
my third grade teacher Mrs kinau
absolutely loved her she read us uh The
Secret Garden and she did all the voices
I just absolutely adored this woman I
thought she was like 160 years old she
was probably like 65 or something but
that's that's part of growing up but
imagine if she was instead of reading
The Secret Garden to us if she was
reading this book about anal rape and
dildos and incest and everything else um
that probably wouldn't have been right
it's not to say those things don't exist
because they do but they are appropriate
at some point and when that point should
be is subjective and that's why parents
ultimately should be the deciders of
what their children are learning and by
the way we all know this which is why
the homeschooling movement and the Pod
movement uh and school choice is
exploding right now because everyone's
realizing boy you know for Generations
now we've been sending these kids to
learn about a whole bunch of weird and
now a bunch of kids have anxiety they
roll on drugs etc etc anyway it
continued with Joy Reed but uh Tiffany
did a fine job here I'm saying to you is
that as you are not an expert in this
book I don't have tot AR appro for
public I mean's is a full context story
as you said of the author's experience
why is it your right or a mom's for
Liberty activist's right to say that a
parent who wants their child to have
access to this book which gives a
personal experience of this author that
they that why doesn't a liberal parent
for instance or a parent of an lgbtq kid
why don't they have a right for their
child to just have access to this book
why is it your right to say they can't
so again we're talking about incest rape
and
pedophilia parent one more no no no each
parent has to decide what is appropriate
for their child to read so I want you to
answer I'm going to ask you one more
time what is your right to tell a parent
who wants their child who might feel
seen by this story why don't they have
the right why don't they have the right
as a parent to say my child can have
access to this book if a child feels
seen by this story that means that they
have been uh the victim of a predator
that means that they have either been
raped by a family member they they've
experienced um and your proof of that is
what you just said that a child feels
seen by this
story what I'm saying you're now making
assumptions about if child has been
raped we should do a lot better than put
a book on Li you're literally creating a
story behind a child that you don't know
let me show you a
form can't say all the things can't say
them nobody's going to make any money
around here if I say them so let me try
to do it nicer first off when Joy keeps
saying uh are you an expert in this book
do you think that that in thus that
would give you the right to criticize
the book do you think the teachers who
are teaching this book or any other book
are experts in this book no they're
Elementary School teachers in public
schools they're not they're not
necessarily the best and the brightest
that's number one number two Joy if you
really want when she talks about the
parents of the lgbtq and and the and the
liberal parents if they really want
their child their fourth grader to learn
about anal rape and all of this other
stuff then give them that book at home
and then guess what Tiffany and moms for
Liberty might have they might question
the ethics or the morality of that
parent but at that point it's not their
right to do anything when we're talking
about a public school every parent gets
on the board right like the parents can
be as involved as they want most parents
obviously over the last two three
decades have not been involved enough so
people like Joy Reed were able to infect
all of these things but if but when Joy
reads like what are you saying
everything should be taught like it just
doesn't even make any
sense